kim zolciak suffers a mini-stroke  the field  just hours after her dancing with the  stars performance Tuesday night Kim  Zolciak found herself in a hospital in  Atlanta she posted this picture to  Instagram quote took the red-eye got  home and within minutes suffered a TI a  mini-stroke and the left side of my body  went completely numb and my speech was  gone Kim says she since regained  complete sensation and speech and will  be released from the hospital sometime  Thursday Kim has been taking redeye  flights between Los Angeles in Atlanta  since dancing with the stars began a  couple weeks ago and judging by her  Instagram posts they're taking a toll  him even said they're making her  delirious